[Musique]
histoire de madame l'api
aujourd'hui 1er rep is able
[Musique]
or
je souhaite
et
[Musique]
là
c'est là
m
[Musique]
dans une campagne verdoyante à l'orée
d'un bois au bord d'un petit ruisseau se
trouve belette ville nom d'une famille
de belette qui s'y installa il ya fort
longtemps belette ville s'étend tout au
long du petit ruisseau et s'enfonce dans
la forêt tout près de la forêt se trouve
la ferme dans la ferme habite le fermier
la fermière et leurs trois enfants
robin saisir et brume
moment
au quesnoy répondu
[Musique]
aa pc vous
mon
au moins comme une âme l'api vient à 1
raconte des choses drôles
on sait tous avec elle tandis que vous
on a raison de dire que ton toujours
enfermés on devient bête en ce n'est pas
le cas des oiseaux de la forêt qui eux
sotoco rendent tout ce qu'il se croit
c'est parce qu'elle était à bord coop
maintenant il est vieux et l'est comme
son père il n'ya pas dire c'était le
plus non tenues tiens on sonne qui ça
peut être dernière et on va ouvrir un
portail mais ne soyez pas si curieuse
[Musique]
la visite c'est le faire confirmer
oui oui et on dirait aussi un nouveau
coq regarde clôture de quel bon mal
c'est pour remplacer note cox fait vieux
c'est pas comme son père qui reste à ce
type au jusqu'à première communion de
robin au teil coq au vin nous avons
mangé la au champignon
oui lardons
[Musique]
et flamber à la maniaque comment
t'appelles-tu d'où viens tu est ce vrai
que c'est toi qui remplacera notre code
le nouveau venu qui pour l'instant
tremblant son coin remplacera-t-il le
vieux coq
nous le saurons bientôt
[Musique]
il
ban
[Musique]
non